والحمد لله
هذا ما تشرحه الزهره لهؤلاء الفتيات
زخرفه تستلم البيئه المحليه وتاخذ من
الطيور وضباء ومن اثارها ملامحه لكسر
عتابه البيوت ووضعي لمسه ترتاح لها النفوس
العيون
داخل المملكه
رحله اعداد هذه النقوش تبدا من خارج
المدينه من هذه الصخور المختلفه الالوان
عمليه شاقه تتطلب مهارات في الرصد
والاكتشاف وتستحق العناء اذ هي مصدر رزق
لا بديل منه للعاملين في هذا المجال
احمر ومنه ما يكون صلدا ومنهما يسهل شقه
وهذا الاخير هو الذي نستخدمه
والله بعد الا صعيبه يا حاج ما يجيبش يكون
صائم هذا عمل صعب جدا وشاق ويتطلب العمل
من الصباح الى المساء سواء بالنسبه للطين
الابيض او الاحمر
الان ما تحتاج اليه من مواد داليه لاعاده
تطريز جدران رشقتها امطار الخريف فمحت ما
كان عليها من نقوش
مهنه تعلمتها منذ 10 سنين وهي من بين اخر
من يمارسها في هذه المدينه الان
طير الاحمر
لا يسمعون الاولاد
لا سيما في المناسبات الاجتماعيه والاعياد
وتلفظ بها النسوه هنا ما على وجه مدينتهنا
من اثر الايام
بمواد خالصه من البيئه المحليه وباساليبها
وطرائق
ترسموا هذه الزخارف والنقوش
تراثيه على المدينه لمسه فن هو جمال
بصريه خاصه
الجزيره موريتانيا